they need to work quickly
their position just a few kilometers
from Enemy Lines is exposed and in the
line of fire the Drone pilot who's known
by his call signed Playboy is scouting
out where best to attack uh here is the
Russians
here is he going to the trench you see
yep
on the screen he can see blocky images
of Russian soldiers marking the
coordinates this position is now a
Target
you can see the Russians over here
I think coming
but they are taking huge risks whilst
they can see the enemy the Russians also
have drones
and they can be easily spotty
this is dangerous work but without this
eye in the sky Ukraine's artillery Crews
would be firing blind
thank you
and further back from the front line
troops from the unit a volunteer platoon
called Carlson which includes foreign
soldiers load up with ammunition
it's going good
um we're pushing them back and they're
falling back unfortunately they're
destroying everything as they go
with winter on its way the fight for
Kirsten has become more desperate
Ukraine eager to take advantage of its
momentum and Russia's retreats
the war here on the southern front is
being fought across Wide Open Fields it
is an artillery battle and it is
absolutely deadly now this team has just
been given the coordinates by the Drone
reconnaissance units and they're heading
now to fire rockets at Russian positions
the launch position has been primed and
it doesn't take long to line up the
targets there is no time to hang around
the firing needs to be done at speed
one
images captured by drones show the
impact it's these kind of barrages that
are forcing the Russians to withdraw
but even before the Smoke Clears the
Ukrainian artillery team are making
their escape they're vulnerable now to a
rapid Counter-Strike
this fight is a clash of nerve and
Firepower and for the moments on this
perilous Frontier Ukraine is winning
Alex Rossi Sky News in Curtin region